2023年我刚加入时，没人会把Anthropic、Claude和编程联系在一起。
我想回到Anthropic刚起步的时候。我记得当时就想，这些人根本没戏，OpenAI领先太多了。
那时候，我看到人们开始用这些模型不仅仅是代码补全，而是真正编写长代码，这让我们看到了训练Opus 3以做得更好的机会。那是一个转折点。
我总想起一年后的Opus 4.5，那是寒假期间，大家都在家写代码。
Opus 4.5的神奇之处在于，我们不仅有了模型，还有了像Claude Code这样优秀的产品体验。没有Claude Code这样的产品，Opus 4.5不会迎来那样的高光时刻；同样，没有Opus 4.5，Claude Code也不会获得如此快速的普及。
我想谈谈产品角色正在发生的变化。
对我的团队来说，提升用户价值的关键在于找到正确的用户反馈。我们团队有句话：评估就是新的产品需求文档。
Garry Tan一直在说，如果你现在愿意每年在token上花10万美元，那你过的就是2028年人们的生活。
你必须像对待像素一样对待token。你必须用模型来构思好主意、更好的主意。这没有捷径。如今，人们对AI工具的目标应该更远大，因为它们的能力太强了。
我常问团队一个问题：假设Claude 8问世，用户的哪些行为会改变？这对你今天的工作意味着什么？
今天的嘉宾是Diane Penn，Anthropic AI研究和实验室团队的产品负责人。她三年多前加入Anthropic，成为第一位技术产品经理——这在AI领域算是很久以前了——当时产品团队只有五名工程师。她帮助推出了从Claude 2到Claude 4的每一款模型，还孵化和发布了Claude Code、MCP、Skills、Claude Design，以及像计算机使用、工具使用和推理这样的核心功能。能和她这样身处AI和产品管理核心的人交谈总是令人受益匪浅。很难想象还有谁比Anthropic研究和实验室团队的产品负责人更了解技术走向。
在我们开始之前，别忘了访问lenniesproass.com，免费获取一年全球最热门、设计最精美的AI产品，仅限Lenny's newsletter订阅者。接下来，有请Diane Penn。Diane，非常感谢你的到来，欢迎来到播客。
谢谢你，Lenny。再次见到你真好。
我想回到Anthropic的早期。我记得Anthropic刚发布首个模型的时候，大概是三年前吧。
是的，三年前。
我记得当时感觉，这些人没戏。OpenAI远远领先，他们怎么想的？怎么可能赶得上？OpenAI已经赢了，太晚了。但现在情况完全不同了。
我最新看到的数据是，Anthropic的年经常性收入（ARR）可能达到500亿美元。这相当于很多公司上市时的估值，而Anthropic每年的收入就达到这个数。你是最早加入的产品经理之一，当时只有五名工程师，模型甚至还没发布。Anthropic早期是什么样子？有什么是现在的人们可能会惊讶的？
我觉得，Anthropic今天能取得这样的成就，很大程度上源于早期就奠定的核心。我是2023年加入的，正如你所说，当时有五名产品工程师。整个API开发只有一名工程师。
如果你相信商业，嗯，我觉得很大一部分原因在于文化非常强大，这也是我想对那些对公司感兴趣的人强调的一点，他们真的是言行一致，践行使命、文化和价值观。
而且那种能量非常像初创公司。你说得对，早期我们确实在努力寻找自己的定位。我觉得有一方面是关于技术的，但技术如何为用户带来价值，为社会带来价值，这可能是什么呢？我觉得早期我们就是在以不同的方式探索这一点。
比如我们确实从cloud.ai开始，像一个聊天助手，然后演变成工具使用之类的东西。
嗯，我认为我们真正开始进入状态的一个时刻是推出了像金门大桥克劳德这样的东西。不知道你还记不记得。不记得了？
嗯，这个实际上只上线了大约24小时。我们刚刚在2024年初发布了一项早期的可解释性研究，其中一个例子基本上是在模型的层内有所谓的特征，这些特征表达了某些主题。
所以研究人员能够识别出的主题之一，比如说，是项目符号写作。另一个是人物和地点。而一个经常出现并且引起共鸣的是金门大桥。
所以当你实际上调高那个特征时，克劳德就会痴迷于金门大桥。也就是说，在它的每个回答中，它都会绕回来说到金门大桥。
所以如果你说：“给我一个做意大利面的食谱。”它会说：“这是食谱，而橙色就像金门大桥的那种国际红。”所以这真的很古怪，我们非常想在这种情况下把那个体验带给大众，带给那些开始使用克劳德的人。
然后整个体验实际上我们在24小时内就在我们的cloud.ai网站上上线了，这需要工程、产品、设计以及我们的研究团队一起合作，我们真的为它感到骄傲。
我想可能只有2000人看到了，说实话。[笑声] 但这让我们觉得，哦，我们实际上可以带来新的用户体验，以不同的方式展示我们的研究，而且这种风格对我们来说很真实，速度也很有初创感。
对我个人来说，那就像是其中一个隐藏的转折点，我们开始找到自己的身份，我们可以打造产品，打造体验，区别于竞争对手已经做出来的东西。
而我觉得显然，实验室、代码之类的，我们随后开始以我们实际认为的世界如何看待AI、如何将AI更贴近公众的方式来定义自己。
嗯，但那是非常自下而上的文化。所以整个经历都是自下而上的。我看到工程师、设计师自愿抽出时间来做这个。
所以我喜欢用这个作为例子来说明早期是什么样的，但文化和价值观我认为从那些早期到现在一直保持着。
本期节目由我们的季度主赞助商WorkOS呈现。OpenAI、Anthropic、Cursor、Vercel、Replit、Sierra、Clay以及数百家其他获胜公司有什么共同点？它们都由WorkOS提供支持。
如果你正在为企业构建产品，你肯定感受到了集成单点登录、SCIM、审计日志以及大公司所需的其他功能的痛苦。WorkOS将这些交易障碍转化为即插即用的API，并提供了专为B2B SaaS构建的现代开发者平台。
实际上，我投资的每家初创公司在向高端市场扩张时，最终都会选择WorkOS。那是因为他们是最好的。
无论你是试图获得第一个企业客户的种子期初创公司，还是正在全球扩张的独角兽公司，WorkOS都是你成为企业就绪并解锁增长的最快路径。它本质上就是企业功能的Stripe。访问workos.com开始使用，或者直接去他们的Slack，那里有真正的工程师在等你回答问题。
WorkOS让你通过令人愉悦的API、全面的文档和流畅的开发者体验更快地构建。今天就访问workos.com，让你的应用成为企业就绪。那么，当你回顾Anthropic从那个试图与OpenAI这个巨头竞争的实验室，发展到今天的样子，还有其他大的转折点吗？有没有什么特别突出的时刻让你觉得“哇，这真的改变了局面”？
绝对是当我们训练和测试Opus 3的时候，我觉得那是公司的一个时刻，我们当时还不到200人，非常清楚我们需要并且想要创造一个前沿模型，这对我们触达用户、消费者和展示我们的研究非常重要。
而且我们在寻找为什么人们应该选择Claude的原因，那是一个核心问题，也是早期我们经常被问到的问题。我觉得Opus 3，你知道，它是在2024年3月初发布的。但之前有很多个月，推理、研究、微调、预训练等各个团队在不同的时刻为了共同目标而团结起来，我认为所有参与的人都非常自豪。
我记得我是产品经理，研究团队，还有我自己，我们当时大概是在12月，所以我们都各自在家，在父母家里，看到每个人的背景都是……
他们童年的房间，大家都非常努力地搞清楚我们到底在为什么训练模型？它是否以正确的方式呈现？所以我觉得在建立大量信任方面，那确实非常有力。
而且我们的许多研究负责人，实际上从那时起，现在都在领导强化学习，领导我们的性格对齐工作。所以那种基础的信任我认为也帮助我们现在与任何模型很好地合作。
无论是产品还是研究，因为我们早期就一起在战壕里工作了那么多。然后我觉得还有一些事情，比如识别出编码很重要。对吗？在2023年我开始的时候，
没有人会把Anthropic和Claude以及编码放在同一个句子里。我认为当时的竞争对手模型像GPT-4，确实有些用于编码，但那只是众多用例之一。而我看到的一件事是，人们开始使用这些编码模型，
不仅用于代码补全，实际上还用于编写长篇幅的代码，那对我们来说是不是一个机会，来训练Opus 3让它在这方面做得更好？结果从训练角度看，变化相对较小，
但它最终帮助我们在早期竞争中脱颖而出，对用户产生了差异化，并且实际上吸引了很多早期的Claude爱好者和开发者，因为我们提供了他们当时认为不可能的价值。
你谈到Opus 3很有趣，那是很久以前了，很难想到那是一个大转折点，听到那在内部是一个大里程碑，真的很意思。那几乎
感觉就像你们建立的信心，哇，我们真的能推出一个前沿模型，这如果和今天相比并不算太好。我总想到Opus 45，有意思的是，大约一年后，
也是在寒假期间，当每个人都在家能编码的时候。那是不是另一个大里程碑？
是的。Opus 45绝对是另一个重要时刻。我认为Opus 45的神奇之处在于，我们现在不仅仅有一个模型，还有一个载体，一个很棒的产品体验，比如Cloud Code。我们团队经常说的一句话是，你需要前沿产品才能拥有前沿模型，
才能让人们感受到前沿模型的魔力。我觉得在那之前几个月，我们就已经感受到了Cloud Code的魔力。
但是，模型本质上达到了一个智能水平，在非常广泛的层面上，用户可以在新的用例中体验前沿智能，让它以智能体的方式端到端地运行事情。我认为那就是转折点。
实际上两者都是。没有像Cloud Code这样的产品，Opus 45就不会有那个时刻；而没有Opus 45，Cloud Code的采用也不会加速到那种程度。
谈到这个话题，有意思的是达里奥，如果你回顾他所有的预测，他就是说，编码问题将在大约一年内100%解决。他一直说
AI将完成我们所有的代码。我记得每个人都觉得，“不可能。这太复杂了。AI怎么可能会真的擅长人类做的这种复杂的事情？
不，这在很长一段时间内都将由人类来做。”他完全正确。他还经常谈到的另一件事是我们现在所处的这个指数。
我记得不久前，新模型发布时，每个人都说，“好了，结束了。没有更多上升空间了。它正在达到平台期。它完了。没有成长空间了。”而现在恰恰相反，
现在我们处于指数曲线内部。从定义上讲，这意味着每一次改进都是一次巨大的跳跃，因为我们正处于曲棍球棒的那段。身处这种AI飞速改进、大量事物被解锁的疯狂历史时刻是什么感觉？
人们应该如何为AI越来越多的进步带来的加速做准备？我想说的一点是，我们中的大多数人还没有积极投入工作，当互联网从新奇事物转变为每个人都能使用的东西时，感觉就像那只是人类。我认为类比是有帮助的。
所以类比一下，我觉得有几件事，第一，适应性变得非常重要。我认为我们有评估。我们有，你知道，在安全方面的安全测试、红队测试，在能力和产品方面，新原型
像Cloud Code、tag等产品，但很难准确预测具体时刻或具体模型，所以适应性变得重要，当你面对新信息时，如何做出更好的决策，而不是坚持原来的计划。
所以这种敏捷性非常重要。我觉得另一部分是，如何真正以第一性原理来思考，推理接下来会发生什么？那又怎样？我们如何投资于新产品？我们如何
投资于向用户解释差异？所以我认为身处那种指数中的很多经验就是，在那种节奏中理解你如何运作并做出更好的决策，然后应用第一性原理思维来采取行动。
可能我们会提前推出一个计划，原本预期几个月后才会发布，但现在模型已经能够实际执行并带给用户了。这就像共同工作的技能标签，你知道，这是一个非常积极的自我强化循环。
而且我认为很大一部分也在于彼此间的信任，确保我们在做正确的决策，并带着大家一起前进。
有些团队可能会更快感受到这种指数级的变化，那么我们如何优雅地带领整个组织，尤其是正在成长中的公司和团队一起适应呢？
所以，我听到的是，你几乎不知道每次模型发布后可能会实现什么功能。因此，关键是要保持适应能力，随着新事物的出现而调整。换句话说，产品本身必须跟上可能性的发展。
再次说到你的观点，模型能做很多事，但人们可能不知道如何操作，甚至无法使用。所以，让产品易于使用，甚至直接告诉你‘你可以做这个’，这似乎是很重要的一部分。你大概就是这个意思吧？
我想是的。我觉得在最初的扩展定律论文中，有一些非常有趣的图表，大家可能很熟悉用计算和数据增加导致损失减少的概念。
也就是说，随着规模扩大，模型变得更智能，这是一个非常平滑的线性曲线。但同样有趣的是，这些图表中还有各种不同的新兴能力曲线。
例如，随着你增加数据和训练计算量，你会看到这些不连续的新兴能力跳跃式增长。模型从不能计算1+1，到能可靠地计算出来。
这些新兴能力，其预测性并非总是准确的，并不是每个人都知道确切的时刻，你需要评估能力来检测。这实际上一直是这项技术工作方式的一部分，也是让安全变得更加困难的原因，因为除非你有评估和测试系统，否则这些跳跃可能在你不知情的情况下发生。
这太有趣了，你可能开发了一个AI大脑，它能做一些你自己都没意识到的事情，所以你的工作的一部分就是发现‘天哪，我们刚刚在这方面变得很厉害’，然后想想能用它做什么。
所以我认为存在‘产品积压’和‘用户积压’的问题，用我们产品经理的话来说，即使是在现有的模型上，我们也有很多可以探索的，尤其是在我们的最新版本上，比如‘Fable’和‘Temple’。这种发现过程实际上是Anthropic早期DNA的一部分，我相信它将继续成为我们在产品、实验室和研究中运营的重要部分。
这让我想到Gary Tan，他是YC的总裁，我不知道他的确切头衔。他有个有趣的观点：如果你现在愿意每年花10万美元在token上，那你就是在体验2028年普通人的生活方式，因为到那时这将会很便宜，每个人都能这样工作。但现在有一个阿尔法机会，就是活在未来，疯狂消费token。所以人们有巨大的机会去了解未来的样子，并更快地构建东西。对于这种‘token最大化’的想法，你有什么看法？
是的，我更多地从产品角度看待。几乎可以说，token消费是输入，而真正的输出是你所描述的实验成果。如果我们围绕实验来设定目标，那可能是更好的结果衡量方式，因此可能还有其他方式来实现那个结果。
我要说的是，在内部，一些最有创意的思考者、最好的原型设计师，确实会花大量时间与每个新版本的研究模型互动。所以你必须使用模型，才能产生好主意、更好的主意，这是无可替代的。当技术变化这么快时，不接触技术就很难想出一个完美的策略。
同时，我认为我们还可以做其他事情，比如我们在Anthropic内部经常做的就是公开工作。早期，当我们的产品面还比较少时，有一个Slack频道，几乎全公司的人都在测试早期版本的Claude，尝试不同的用例。他们不叫它用例，但你可能让它编辑一篇文章，或者想出发送邮件的最佳方式。
这些都是不同的用例，但我们都公开工作。然后你会神奇地看到，不同的用户或团队成员想出一个点子，其他人尝试不同的变体，然后在大约10次请求之内，就会产生一些神奇的东西或潜在的新用例。我认为这不仅在于个人独自摸索，更在于这种协作。
他们自己怎么用这个技术。我觉得我们在做实验的时候，可以更多地促进那种集体发现。实验不一定总是一个人的单打独斗。
这很有意思。是的。这个想法就是，我们不确定这东西能做什么，或者我们能用它做什么，需要大家不断摸索，尝试各种东西，听听别人在尝试什么，搞清楚
什么可能。这样的技术很有趣，还是说就像是，哦，我弄明白了它能做这个，你打算拿它做什么？
我觉得从大的主题来说，我们知道这些模型能写很好的文章，或者写长篇的文本，但具体的痛点是什么，你能用这个解决什么，然后把它带到用户层面，让
人们能用，我认为这更像是探索或者实验性的东西。
顺着这个话题，你负责实验室团队的产品，这非常酷。我们之前请过Ben man和Mike Griger上播客，他们都在实验室工作，聊过实验室。实验室是什么？实验室出了什么成果？很多
人都听说过这些东西，它们是怎么运作的，让它们能在核心的Anthropic产品团队之外创造出这么多创新的想法。实验室的论点在很多方面是识别并深挖那些
可能不在核心路线图中的不连续的大赌注，看看有没有搞头，还有这个搞头的10倍、100倍、1000倍是什么。所以比如说，像Cloud Code这样的东西，我觉得
我听说过[笑]。比如Cloud Code，还有Skills，最近还有Cloud Design MCP。我们在团队里真正强调的一点是，尤其是在现在，有太多东西
可以构建，那么不连续的赌注意味着什么呢？我认为我们今年采取的一种方法是，你可以对主题或领域有非常坚定的看法，但对确切的原型则要更灵活一些。
所以，这里有一种实验文化。有很多自下而上的东西，团队里的工程师非常自主，自我驱动去测试不同的想法。有时候我们有一个论点，但可能还不行，所以我们随后
可能会在一到两代模型之后重新审视它。所以，这些原型即使最终没有直接发布，也能帮助我们学习，这也是有价值的。所以我认为
这使得实验室的孵化和使命能够真正加速，为Anthropic更广泛地看到拐角。想到在已经如此创新和
有创造力，而且发布速度惊人的Anthropic内部还要再设一个实验室团队，这很有趣。是什么让实验室运作得这么好？因为你列出了所有这些产品，而且感觉像是Anthropic发布的最大的成功几乎都来自这里。我肯定还有很多我现在没想到的。对于在更大的公司内部创建一个成功的实验室，核心是什么？我认为
团队文化，就像Anthropic整体一样，团队文化非常宝贵。我觉得Ben设定了一个令人难以置信的愿景，推动人们思考想法的10倍、100倍，而且我们的团队，实验室内的
小组很小。有时候这些想法是从一个工程师开始的，对吧？而且我认为，有时候当有非常大的团队去追求非常模糊的大想法时，你最终会因为这一点而慢下来。所以我认为这就是
文化。我认为我们实际上也会选择那些真正想做这种从0到1实验的人，这并不容易。有很多赌注我们最终会放弃或关掉。而且也许，你懂的，我们会重新审视它们，在
未来。但那很难。当你全身心投入，像一个创始人一样为一个赌注拼搏，但还没成功时，这是很难的。所以我认为这就是那种性格类型的人，那些真正
对从0到1充满热情和深入研究的人。
你领导研究团队的产品工作，你和Anthropic的研究人员一起工作。很多人对研究是什么、研究人员做什么有点了解。我觉得很多人并不完全理解
这些在AI实验室里非常有价值的人。我的思考方式，我想帮助人们理解，也帮我理解，研究人员整天都在做什么呢？我猜他们有一个关于如何改进模型的假设。
他们找数据，调整算法，检查调整训练方式，然后测试，看看效果如何，不断迭代，不断寻找改进模型的方法。大致是这样吗？或者说帮我们理解一下
研究人员整天在做什么？
这确实，我觉得这可能是很多日常的工作。不过关于研究人员和研究组织，比如在Anthropic，还有一点是，他们对未来有一种更广泛的愿景。所以比如，像
嗯，我觉得即使在公司创立之初，研究人员就在讨论如何让Claude使用电脑，如何让人工智能操作屏幕。所以其实有很多创始人精神，我是这么形容的。
在研究人员中，尤其是那些非常大胆和有抱负的研究人员，我们Anthropic有很多这样的人。所以对这项技术能走多远有一个愿景，然后我认为在循环的另一端，既然这项技术或Claude已经在用户手中，我们如何让它今天变得更好？所以这是一个中长期问题，同时也有很多精力在思考未来的视角，以及眼前和短期内我们可以改进的地方。
所以我觉得你描述的感觉很好，我们如何对不同版本的Claude进行迭代改进？我的团队与研究人员合作的方式是高度融入这些循环，特别是在对用户有重大影响的领域。
比如视觉、计算机使用、编码、代理编码、工具使用、测试时计算，这些直接影响用户体验的方面，然后想办法把用户反馈带回给研究人员，以他们能理解且能采取行动的方式呈现。
我认为第二部分其实是工作中很大的一部分，有时也是困难的部分。比如，我们可能会在Claude.ai上收到反馈，说Claude产生了幻觉，这很模糊。如果你告诉研究人员“请修复Claude的幻觉问题”，这不太可行。
所以团队的工作之一是理解用户给出反馈的轨迹，以及是否同意。我们会查看Claude当时应该调用什么工具，或者基于它当前的知识，或者它调用了正确的工具，查看了正确的文档，但提取了错误的事实。
第一种情况是工具使用失败，第二种情况是搜索或知识及搜索综合失败，或者可能是对齐问题。所以把这些细节带给研究人员，判断这是否是一个足够大的问题，制定评估标准，然后描述我们如何改进。
这些就是可操作性的层面，也是研究人员的日常语言。所以我们尽量贴近如何以可操作的方式将用户反馈传递到核心模型训练和研究开发循环中。
我前几天跟一个人聊过，感觉研究AI研究现在是成功人生的好去处。从你看来，要成为一个真正成功的研究人员需要什么？不是每个人都能进入，也不是每个人的大脑都适合，但假设有人想探索这条职业道路，从你观察到的情况来看，怎样才能成功呢？
研究人员通常是研究人员或与研究人员合作的产品经理。
两者都做吧，但研究人员和产品经理型的研究人员也会非常成功。但感觉每家公司都在挖顶尖研究人员，所以我知道你不是AI研究员，但就你观察而言，要在这条职业道路上取得成功需要什么呢？
是的，我认为在Anthropic，很多最成功的研究人员和研究领导都是对问题进行第一性原理思考的人。他们推理问题非常透彻，对自己的研究领域充满热情，并且对未来有大胆的设想，同时又能贴近细节。
比如我们的领导、首席科学家、微调团队和强化学习团队的负责人，他们都深入训练运行，查看评估结果和底层数据。保持贴近细节并乐在其中，是强研究人员和发展品味的标志。
我觉得另一部分是他们的长期思考能力和雄心，比如Dario，我们相信可以改变软件工程。朝着那个方向走，你会学到很多，你得仰望星空，在很多方面都要敢想，我认为这是成功研究人员的必备素质。
我喜欢“更大胆”这个梗，现在经常出现，但很难做到。说容易，做难，你能想多大？这正是AI解锁的潜力。更大胆。
是的。
我认为要思考一两次然后坚持，对领域要固执，但方法要灵活。这是我们在挑战自己的问题，但技术是……
AI发展太快了，你怎么确保自己正在构建的东西能适应未来？实际上，我认为这也是核心产品开发循环的一部分，要思考得更宏大。我常问团队的一个问题是...
当我们构建产品时，假设Claude 8出来了，用户会怎么变？这对你今天构建的东西意味着什么？它能适应那个未来的体验吗？
所以，把野心落到实处很重要。野心是广泛的，所以要想办法具体描述它。
而且，是的，一切都朝着一个连贯合理的方向发展，而不是朝着一个完全不同的方向野心勃勃。说到野心和Claude 8，Fable Mythos最近似乎达到了一个全新的临界点...
以前是有了一个很棒的模型，发布出来，告诉大家“Opus 4.5出来了，大家都能用”。但Mythos走了一条完全不同的路。它被封了，受到了很多审查...
很多人担心它的能力。所有公司都得确保它不会黑进他们的系统。感觉现在每个模型，因为越来越强，都会受到更多审查，并且对谁能使用它们也会有更多限制，这似乎是个大事。你怎么看？这改变了你们的运作方式吗？
我可能会把政策和出口管制方面留给负责这些的同事。我认为产品问题以及我们如何在内部与这些模型互动，正如你提到的，随着前沿模型能力越来越强...
安全防护、红队测试、预发布流程也需要快速演进以适应这些变化。举个例子，在Fable模型之前，我们并没有那么强大的后备用户体验和系统...
因为我们的目标是确保这项技术有不对称的好处，同时最大程度地减少负面影响或严重风险。所以我们构建了后备系统...
这样用户仍然能从Opus 4得到很好的响应。所以我认为，随着我们演进和改进安全系统，我们需要思考如何继续开发和提供出色的用户体验。我认为我们在这两方面都可以做得更多。
所以你会看到我们在创新，改进我们所说的“模型安全包”，在接下来的几周和几个月里会越来越多。
这里真正有趣又出乎意料的是，这为Anthropic创造了一个真正的优势，你能接触到最新的东西。每个实验室都会这样，每个人都会不断改进...
这就在实验室内部创造了一种不公平的优势，能接触到其他人还无法使用的最佳工具，而这些工具超出了你的控制范围。你更希望所有人都能使用它。所以这是一个有趣的新反馈循环即将开始...
那些如此先进的模型只有某些公司能够访问，这将是所有这些限制带来的一个全新的、意想不到的二级效应。我们的目标是开发这些系统和模型，尽可能包容。
我认为我们的目标是不要让这种情况发生在通用用途的技术上，而是要让它更易获取。这是我们目前的首要任务之一，去减少我们看到的那种情况。
没错，这很合理。我猜你会希望尽可能多的客户，尽可能多的人使用这个东西。本期节目由Mercury赞助播出，这是一种颠覆性的银行服务，深受超过30万企业家的喜爱，现在还有了Command功能...
我使用Mercury已经超过六年了，我从未想过要离开。Mercury基本上就是由产品人而非银行家打造的银行服务。他们让开发票、转账、为团队设置虚拟卡变得如此简单，我甚至可以说有趣。
你的银行有API吗？有终端原生CLI吗？有AI就绪的MCP服务器吗？我觉得没有。而且就在最近，他们推出了Command，这是一个内置于Mercury的对话界面，充当你的财务助手。
我一直在用Command来转账，看看我在哪些类别上花费最多，分析我的现金流。就在今天，我用它查了过去一年从某个特定赞助商那里赚了多少钱。我就问：“过去一年我从X那里赚了多少？”十秒钟后，答案就出来了。真是太酷了。
访问mercury.com了解更多并在线申请，几分钟就能搞定。Mercury是一家金融科技公司，不是FDIC投保的银行。银行服务由Choice Financial Group和Column NA提供，均为FDIC成员。
我想谈谈产品角色如何变化，以及在这个新世界里谁在表现出色——现在AI已经成为我们生活的核心部分。当你招聘产品经理、产品人员时，当你在寻找当今世界表现出色的人时，你注意到哪些特点？
你最看重什么？你更看重哪些方面？哪些趋势在上升，哪些在下降？实际上，在我的团队中，我们的招聘流程三年来没有变过。
所以我们真正看重的是，评估通用型人才的标准——比如产品经理中的通才，研究型产品经理——其实一直是一样的。我认为其中几个特质，第一就是第一性原理思考。
这真的不是套用你以前在消费产品或者B2B SaaS领域的经验模式，而是真正要弄清楚，在当下这个时刻，对于这个用户群体，用这项技术，用户价值到底是什么。
有没有一个例子？很多人听到第一性原理思考，都会说，对对，我知道，我很擅长。但真正展现出色第一性原理思考的人，是什么样的？
我觉得一个例子是，你可能认为产品经理的工作就是制定产品策略和交付用户价值，但我每天是通过写PRD或产品愿景文档来体现的。而对我的团队——研究型产品经理来说，推动用户价值的方式是找到正确的用户反馈，也就是评估，对吧？然后这些评估就可以成为用户需求的具体体现。所以我们确实会写一些产品文档和PRD，但我们团队有句话叫，
评估就是新的PRD，对吧？因为要交付用户价值，不再依赖于过去一二十年人们习惯写的那个文档了，这是一种新的工作方式。所以第一性原理思考就是让我想想为了实现目标，我应该做什么，而不是说，我以前做过这些事，所以我继续这么做。
所以这里的意思是，以前是大概有个想法，写个PRD，跟人聊，对齐计划，设计，开发，上线，看效果，然后迭代。我听到的是，现在比如有了一些反馈，说哪里有问题或者有机会，第一步就是用评估来定义工作内容，而不是PRD。
也许也许第一步是理解用户的痛点。而接触用户痛点的方式也不同了，对吧？过去我们可能会做用户访谈，而且如果你深入下去，可能会让用户带你走一遍他们的使用流程，看那些界面细节。现在呢，你得像关注像素一样关注token。所以，我们团队有一项工作就是阅读对话记录，深入理解那些失败的轨迹，
然后判断这是不是幻觉？是Claude过度自信了吗？失败的主题其实有很多细微差别，然后这就能让你建立一个对痛点的细致描述。这样基本上就可以形成一个新的评估，而且这个评估要覆盖各种情况，既要包含那些失败的正向场景，也要涵盖那些本不该失败的方面，
然后把这些问题反馈给研究团队，这样我们就能做出改进，并且实际衡量质量，比如当Opus 5.5出来的时候，这个领域是否改善了，Claude现在能不能准确找到文档中的正确位置，并提取出正确的综合信息。所以这一切都是为了可操作性，缩短从发现问题到采取行动的距离，特别是对于我们的利益相关者和合作伙伴团队，比如研究人员，让他们能够快速采取行动。
有没有一个例子？你发现了一个问题或机会，然后写了评估？在大多数情况下，评估是什么样的？当人们想想象评估时，他们会想到什么？
我们实际上是在Anthropic内部开创了这个概念。所以早期的一个例子是，早期的Claude模型在遵循特定格式方面表现不佳。比如输出JSON之类的，而现在这是Claude成为优秀智能体的基础，对吧？如果你不能输出特定格式，你就不知道如何调用API，无法使用工具等等。所以最初的端到端是，我听到反馈说Claude 2时代，
Claude在遵循指令方面不太好。然后我深入用户，问他们，你说Claude不擅长遵循指令是什么意思？告诉我具体是什么情况，具体是哪个段落？你问了什么？Claude是怎么回应的？要深入到那个细节。然后我发现，早期大约80%的失败反馈都是关于Claude写不对JSON。
然后，好吧，我们先生成30到40个Claude没做对的例子。然后这些就成了你的评估集。你可以有一个提示和一个响应。如果这个响应不符合你预期的标准答案，那就说明这个评估是有价值的，因为它一致地识别出了痛点。然后我们把它加入评估库。当我们有新版本的Claude时，我们会运行这个评估来检查。
我认为到现在这个评估一直都是100%通过或99.9%通过。所以它不再是痛点了。但在早期，就是要把用户反馈，弄清楚他们到底是什么意思，能否复现，是否一致，是不是个大问题，然后想办法把它标准化，让研究人员能用。这基本上就是PM的测试驱动开发，这就是我们现在所处的世界。
先写测试。所以现在写评估已经成了Anthropic产品经理工作的核心部分了吗？
我觉得是这样。我还跟其他公司的Peña聊过，我也觉得这越来越成为更广泛的技能组合，因为我们建的很多产品都处在模型与“缰绳”的交汇点上。
也就是说要为特定用户提供一系列上下文。所以，拥有像eval这样的东西，不仅仅是给做模型的人用的，而是让产品团队普遍能获得更好的用户体验，因为你无法改进你无法衡量的东西。
而很多这种东西仍然很依赖触觉，依赖判断力。所以你必须贴近细节。
而且它也非常不确定，这是很大一部分原因，就像它每次不会给你相同的答案。所以你得把它描述得更宽泛一些。它不会是精确匹配。所以这真的是产品运作方式的一个有趣变化，而eval是其中重要的一部分。你们还做PRD吗？还有那种一页纸描述问题的方式吗？还是说已经变成“玩”了？好，你现在摇头了。是的，
我们确实有，我觉得当问题非常明确的时候，eval几乎可以作为一种速记。我觉得在其他情况下，PRD确实很有价值。PRD是让一大群人对体验和目标的真相来源达成一致的绝佳工具。
所以当我们有一个模型的时候，实际上我们每个模型都有PRD，不一定是为了我们的研究人员，更多是为了我们不断增长的产品界面，为了我们的工程团队，为了我们的利益相关者，比如法律和安全等，作为我们想要实现目标的真相来源，这样一大群人就能朝同一个方向划船。
另一个我觉得PRD有价值的地方是在更模糊的问题和机会上。比如如果我们还没发布像“计算机使用”这样的东西，我们不一定有一组用户特定的痛点。
我认为PRD中产品愿景的部分很有价值，它可以探索即使技术还没准备好让所有人都能用，你如何让它对某个群体有效。这样你可以探索价值，可以给某个用户群体带来连贯的东西。
所以我们确实有PRD。我觉得现在应用方式有点不同了。
好的，这很棒。我刚刚和Andrew聊过，他是OpenAI的Codex应用负责人，你们观点一致。PD没死，对特定项目和想法还是很有用。好的，我们刚刚结束了……
……结束了关于“纯净”还在继续的话题。好的，我们一直在聊产品人需要哪些新技能。你发现那些在这个新的AI世界里做得好的人，特别是产品经理和产品团队成员，还有什么共同模式有变化吗？有没有什么你觉得“好吧，这个你得改变”或者“你得找更多这样的人”的东西？我觉得也许特别是对于……
……可能是中层职业或者更多处于管理职位、产品领导职位的人。有一点我感受很深的是，要成为管理使用这种技术的团队和PM的好经理，你自己必须非常亲力亲为，不只是花时间摆弄，而是真正用这种技术发布产品，并且再次深入细节，和你的PM、工程师以及团队一起“ sweating the tokens”。所以甚至对于我招的那些经验更丰富的PM，入职计划也和那些早期职业的人完全一样，都是关于理解用户、阅读经同意的用户反馈、和客户交谈。
我觉得还有一点是能够理解该怎么做，什么看起来是好的，并且通过非常亲力亲为的方式培养这种能力。这很重要。这不是说一个人如果自己没有亲自构建过，就很容易理解或者看到好的AI产品或功能应该是什么样子。所以，我觉得，我确实强烈觉得，如果你是一个经理，你必须亲力亲为。你必须花一部分时间实际去发布产品。你必须设身处地地站在团队的角度思考。我总是会留出一部分时间，当有模型的时候，自己负责一两个工作流，以便保持我的“心理理论”，保持我对模型如何发展、改进多快的感觉，这样我就能帮助团队做出决策，做出更好的决策。
所以我在这里听到的是，无论你在公司的层级中处于什么位置，如果你不自己动手构建，不真正去和Claude对话，和Codex对话，去构建东西，你就不会成功。
而且你应该在和这种技术合作时感到有趣。我觉得这是另一部分。我认为不管级别如何，最成功的人会是那些喜欢和AI工作，并且探索、实验，不仅花时间实验，还真正端到端地亲自动手发布产品，获取用户反馈的人。我觉得这对每个人来说都是基本的。
我百分之百懂你的意思。就像我坐在我的通讯和这个播客上，只是谈论一些东西，然后说“嗯，那听起来不错”。但每次我真正去构建东西，摆弄各种小细节，
看到这些项目的时候，你心里会想，哦，我明白怎么回事了。然后你会得到更多的体验，很难准确描述你实际和模型一起工作、构建东西时的感受，但就像
进入了一个全新的世界，你会想，哦，我懂了，这就是他们说的计算机使用，这就是他们提到的局限性，以及这种用户体验上的问题。
是的。
所以，是的，就像你说的，你提出了一个很有趣的观点，就是你必须从中找到乐趣，这对很多人来说并不容易，因为他们是被迫使用AI，或者他们根本不知道拿它做什么。
对于有些人来说，他们觉得，我不知道，这太烦人了，我不得不做这个。我不明白这有什么好的，我讨厌这玩意儿，为什么我要和它一起工作？变化太快了，我都累了。那么，有什么建议
能帮助人们找到这种工作中的乐趣呢？我想重申我之前说过的一点，那就是实验不是一个人的事。就像我觉得，在我触及了
几乎所有版本的研究模型，以及到目前为止二十个版本的Claude生产模型之后，我觉得乐趣的一部分来自于看到别人发现新的使用案例。所以，一个想法可能是和一个很兴奋的人结对，
在你关心的一个使用案例上一起探索，而不是自己琢磨出完美的使用案例，因为那可能感觉像工作。和他人一起工作很多时候会带来快乐。
我们还能做些什么来带动其他人呢？这很像，很多时候我们内部会有个充满好奇心的人，然后他们分享一个新原型的想法，这就会吸引更多
人，他们就会想，哦，我不知道这个现在能和Claude一起用。所以这里有一些良性的循环，以及一些方法，来保持这种技术带来的乐趣。
你说得太对了。我想这也是为什么Twitter对很多人来说很有用，因为你看到别人分享他们做过的事情，
然后它会激发你自己的小点子，同时分享你做过的东西也很有趣。
所以这真的是个好建议，就是找一些其他人一起玩，寻找使用案例。我也常听到人说，找一个你想在生活或工作中解决的问题，然后打开Claude
代码，告诉它你想做什么，你会发现即使只是模糊地知道问题，你也能走得很远。是的，我想难点在于有太多不同的事情可以尝试。
是的。
所以你要么专注于与人配对，和那些对这技术充满热情的人一起工作，要么找一些你能立即找到价值的事情。无论选哪个，
这些都能让你深入，而不是对太多的事情浅尝辄止。我觉得很难跟上外面那些原型或产品的数量，所以我的方法是，选择一两个深入进去。
我自己也是这样。你说的太有意思了，因为正是如此。我们刚刚做了一项调查，是我和同事诺姆一起做的，问我的读者他们对现在科技界的情况，
以及AI的感受，其中一个最有趣的发现是，幸福感恰恰就像你说的，深入一两件事，而不是尝试一大堆小事情。找到几件事真的
做好，然后深入进去，因为很多人感到快乐的时候，是他们终于解锁了一种方式，让AI真正改善他们的生活，而不是只是那些乱七八糟、半途而废的东西。
是的，这就像如何从仅仅勾选一个复选框开始？我们作为产品人，这其实是一种对时间和精力的产品优先级排序。如果目标是在实验中寻找乐趣，那么
你需要哪些输入呢？是的，我觉得Anthropic的秘诀就在于文化、工作的自下而上的性质，以及这种公开实验的态度。
通过这种方式，很重要的是如何带动其他人。我觉得最终这会很有价值。是的，我从各个实验室都听到过这样的话，没人确切知道这些要怎么用，
很多就是早点发布，看看人们怎么用，看看有什么可能，然后用这些信息来构建真正的产品并引领潮流。
是的，是的。
我很好奇，关于找到AI在工作生活中帮助你的途径，你最近作为产品经理，有没有什么有意思的方式在用Claude？我觉得有很多东西，比如...
你知道，像故事和标签这类东西。我觉得标签还在很早期阶段，我想到的是，你如何在一个不同的范式下工作，让一个智能体去干活，然后把产品和体验带回来给你。
有一个领域，虽然不是最近的，但我经常跟团队提，我觉得我们可以在用AI上做得更多，就是如何用它来更好地跟彼此沟通，成为更好的管理者。这不一定是提高我们构建的体验的智商，但也确实，我经常用它来准备如何进行更好的对话，特别是在关键时刻的对话中。
我超爱那本书，我实际上有一个技能，帮助我判断我是否在根据当下情况提供合适的细节级别，这真的让我成为更好的管理者，更好的团队支持者。
所以，对于团队里的管理者来说，我一直在跟他们分享，怎么用Claude来让你成为更好的教练。
因为有时候找到完美的词语很难，而模型有很多完美的词语。
我觉得这能在情商方面增强我们，而不只是智商。哦天，这里好多有趣的东西。所以，为了理解你在做什么，你建了一个技能。
你让Claude建立了一个技能，从《关键对话》这本书中吸取经验，而它已经足够了解这本书了，你甚至不需要给它内容。然后你用这个技能和Claude对话，比如‘我马上要和一个同事进行一场很艰难的对话’。
给我一些处理建议。
是的。这真的很棒，几乎就像个性化的教练，针对如何让你... 我们整天都在切换上下文，有Claude帮我配对，帮我... 有时候我可能不会用Claude的建议，但它确实对头脑风暴很有帮助。我是不是在正确地思考反应？我如何能更快地深入？更快建立信任？更直接？
是的，老兄，我有很多问题。这太有趣了。其中一个就是，有人担心人们会开始像AI写东西那样说话，因为他们跟AI交流太多了，就像‘Diane，不是这个，而是那个’。我知道你不是那样，但这是人们的一个担忧。让我问问这个。你担心这个吗？就是人们说的脑腐、萎缩之类的。
我们现在太依赖AI了，我们停止学习和思考，你对这个怎么看？你离AI这么近，而且一直和它融在一起。
对我来说，很多思考和写作过程是连在一起的。所以我觉得有些方式我用Claude来增强我的思考，但我想确保的是，也许这就是你描述的，Claude不会接管我所有的思考。所以我觉得取决于情况，取决于我想在多大程度上保留个人判断，我可能会先提出自己的观点，然后和Claude一起探讨。
确保我保持自己的感觉和语气。然后还有其他事情，比如更新，我们有月度业务回顾，那种情况下更多是想要标准化的，我真的希望它能把信息提炼得很清晰，也许我有一个技能，我们在改进那个技能，但我想达到一个点，就是月度业务回顾的写作，它的价值可能不对称地低于思考本身，所以如何把那部分完全委托给Claude，而我更多是审查和验证信息的人。所以我觉得这取决于你用Claude做什么，你想传达什么，以及委托给Claude是否有不对称的价值。
我还听到的第一个建议真的很棒，就是先想，有自己的观点，然后把Claude当作一个陪练伙伴来发展想法，反驳想法。
是的。是的。我觉得这就是为什么我们的对齐研究和安全研究很有帮助，因为你不想的是一个AI只是同意你，对吧？你想要的是这个技术...
实际上，辅助并成长，最终达到更好的结果。所以有时候，让Claude反驳我反而让我变得更好。这很棒。就像同事一样，当我的想法还不成熟时，我希望有人能提出异议。
我想多听听这个。但我听说当Ben man上播客时，他谈到了Claude内置的宪法，以及我们如何不直观地工作，并像你说的那样关注安全和一致性，还有这部宪法。
它描述了Claude应该如何思考和运作。你可能会认为这样会限制Claude的能力，让它变得不那么有趣和好玩。但恰恰相反，Claude是性格最有趣的。我经常听到这样的评价。
经常有人说，我更喜欢和Open Claw聊天，它众所周知是基于Claude构建的，但后来人们被迫——我们就不深入了——被迫换到其他平台，然后他们说这太差了，这不是我习惯交流的对象。
所以，我认为这是一个非常有趣的点，我想确保我们花点时间讨论。为什么是这样？为什么专注于一致性、安全性，有清晰的宪法，反而使Claude更好、更有趣？而且，
为了让Claude尽可能聪明和能干，让它能在关键点上反驳，而不是只说“是”或“不是”，实际上帮助你得出更好的结论。所以，
我用Claude来帮助处理一些事情，比如我们为下一代Claude制定的定价决策是否正确。这有点元，但用研究版的Opus，让它自己决定如何定价，然后得出更好的结果，这是最终目标。所以，让AI不仅仅是一个助手，不仅仅是一个执行者，不仅仅是接受任务，而是检查它是否在做正确的事情。这实际上与
知道何时反驳密切相关。
知道何时应该主动出击。主动性不一定是按计划行事，而是知道何时提出新想法。所以，为了让Claude更实用，
整体的方法就是让它知道何时该反驳。这是模型整体特征的核心部分。
太有趣了。有意思的是，它不那么顺从几乎是让它更好、更有用的关键，因为我们确实需要这样。比如，我遇到过很多人说：“嘿，AI告诉我我是对的。”但我希望别人也能这样。
是的。这又回到了我们之前关于思维的讨论，对吧？你怎么保护你的思维？
如果你有一个能当思维伙伴的AI，思维伙伴不只是同意你，它应该为你增添价值，而你在一天结束时应该因为与Claude合作而拥有更好的想法。那应该是核心目标，而不只是让你的想法好10%。
是的，我喜欢这个，因为以前常说“十倍思考”。创始人常推动人们：“如果我们把这个十倍化会怎样？”而我经常听到的是：“我们如何从这个想法中实现千倍？”最雄心勃勃的版本是什么？我想回到我们刚才讨论的与Claude持续对话时的思考。很明显，
当AI写了东西时，我们仍然能看出来。有趣的是，它是一个大型语言模型，你会认为它最擅长写作，但奇怪的是，没有AI真正擅长写作，但一眼就能看出是AI写的。你觉得我们会到达一个无法分辨是否AI写的境地吗？
我认为这取决于你想通过识别来实现什么目标。是的，什么是评估标准？实际上，我认为我们可以做更多来让Claude写得更好。实际上，在我的团队和研究方面，我们有非常积极的努力来让Claude写得更好。通常，我认为应该清楚某个想法是由你（Lenny）还是我（Diane）主导的。我认为这真的取决于写作的目标。比如，对于月度业务回顾，我其实希望由Claude从头到尾写。
而且显然，不要让它感觉像人写的。你提出的点很有趣：是不是知道它是AI写的对我们更好，还是不知道？
是的。但也许这个视角更像是关于可验证性，或者由谁来验证。
对，输出。对，对。就像是谁来签字确认。嗯，可能更少关注谁在写，而是谁在验证，谁来签字。这比谁在写更重要。
为什么你觉得AI不擅长写作？我猜它已经研究过人类所有最好的写作了。它已经找出了最好的写作方式。现在我们和它只是，写作的方式也就这么多。
所以我们只是认识到，好吧，这就是AI能做的。它有一些俗套。这是核心原因吗？还是有别的东西让它不能成为伟大的作家？讽刺的是，作为一个大语言模型，
你会觉得它肯定很擅长语言。
我觉得部分原因是我们需要更多投资于训练改进，让AI在写作等领域持续强大。嗯，我觉得这也像我们提到的，技术是参差不齐的。所以有时候当
模型擅长写作但不擅长代理行为时，我们的论点是，我们如何让模型更具代理性，或者调用正确的工具。现在这方面有所改进，那么这些其他领域实际上就成了新的短板。
所以我觉得我们正处于写作这样的时刻，我们确实需要专注于优先训练模型在这个领域变得出色，这对我们来说是一个非常活跃的领域，就像你提到的。
好的，我很高兴。而且，一旦AI变得如此出色，以至于我们都说“我不知道这是谁写的”，但正如你所说，有时我们实际上想知道这是AI写的。这真的很有趣。我
从没这么想过。另一个有趣的地方是，有个喜剧演员开玩笑说，我们在飞机上，Wi-Fi断了，我们就会说：“搞什么鬼？这飞机上Wi-Fi怎么不能用。这
太烂了。你怎么敢？”当你在空中像鸟一样飞行的铁管里时，你怎么还抱怨Wi-Fi不能用。你的观点是，我们取得了巨大的进步，拥有了巨大的力量，但我们不能解决所有问题。我们
不能让所有东西都完美运行。所以基本上AI写作不是优先事项，但现在感觉那里有了更多投资。
是的，我觉得语气和性格是优先事项。我认为技术的进步是一个持续的过程，所以我们看到代理行为有了飞跃或涌现，这是一个新的
常态，然后这些其他能力也需要继续改进。
而且我觉得一旦我们改进了，比如说写作、语气和性格，我们可能会说：
我们如何让Claude更主动？生产力是一个机会，这是人性，我们想让自己变得更好，我们想让这项技术变得更好。嗯，所以我觉得我们把它应用于
AI是正确的，我们应该让它变得更好。
我想问你几个问题，我经常问那些从事未来核心工作的人。一是你认为未来几年人脑在哪些方面会继续最有价值？我知道Anthropic的
使命和愿景是达到通用人工智能、超级智能。所以未来也许没有哪里，但在我们到达那里之前，在我们接近那个时间线时，你认为人脑在哪些方面会继续最有价值？
我们开始讨论让Claude和模型在判断力方面变得更好，特别是最近一年左右。我觉得判断力是一个方面，它积累了大量细微差别和经验，这些
系统没有像人类那样经历过那么多，所以我觉得来之不易的判断力是产品领导者以及总体来说继续至关重要的一个领域。AI能构建的东西太多了。
哪些是实验室应该构建的？很多都需要人类判断力，持久性，主动性，这些都是超越一般能力的行为和
特征，比如那些级别的人如何得到最佳解决方案，如何创造最佳体验。所以我觉得这些特质实际上是触觉特质，我认为它们将继续重要。嗯，
我觉得还有很多能力和专业知识也很重要。你知道，软件工程已经被AI彻底改变了。我觉得像生物学、生命科学这样的领域，这些都是
我们只是处于指数增长的起点，比如软件工程可能就已经在指数上了。我们处于其他一些领域的指数上。我们还没完全达到。所以我觉得你看到我们发布像Cloud
Science这样的产品，投资于这些领域，因为这些都是将技术带给社会并对社会产生积极影响的领域。所以我觉得那里还有很多工作要做。
另一个我想问的问题是，作为有孩子的人，你怎么看待鼓励他们学什么？或者你觉得你会引导他们在这个即将进入的疯狂新世界里取得成功吗？
其实我觉得很多特质跟咱们小时候差不多。
比如对学习的好奇心、坚持不懈、相信自己的内心声音，并且培养和相信自己的内心声音。我有四岁和八岁的孩子，帮助他们是我的责任。
培养他们有自己的主见并敢于表达，对我来说，鼓励这种能力很重要，我觉得这类技能在未来很重要。
要有他们自己的个人声音。
这太有意思了。这和你之前回答我关于如何避免大脑退化、避免过度依赖AI时说的很相关，就是保持自己的观点和视角，不要过度依赖AI。你描述的从小培养孩子们这一点真的很重要。
这太有趣了，我喜欢这种把判断力、坚持和个人观点联系起来的想法。
是的。
对孩子和成年人都一样。
是的。考虑过你孩子的事吗？
哦，天哪。我考虑的问题是，什么时候让他们接触AI，你知道，我孩子三岁，还太早，但你怎么让他们开始接触这个疯狂的东西呢？
我最近参加一个活动，很多父母在讨论怎么看待AI对孩子的影响，有个人提出了一个很有意思的方法：让他们用很早期的模型，这样他们还得挣扎一下，不能立刻得到所有答案。
我觉得那很有意思，比如开源的本地模型。
不太稳定。
对。
对。好奇心是我一直提到的，Ben Man，他回答这个问题的话我一直记着，就是好奇心和他对蒙台梭利的推崇，我们也在鼓励孩子这样做。所以这有点道理。也许最后一个问题，顺着这个思路，Fiona Fun最近在播客里建议我问你：作为母亲，身处AI风暴中心，同时还要工作，你怎么保持精力充沛不 burnout？我们在Anthropic做研究，就像我们正经历前所未有的时代，在外面都觉得疯狂，我都不知道里面是什么样的。你学到了什么关于避免倦怠、保持精力和理智的方法？在2024年，我们全年发布了四个模型或四个系列模型，但今年光第二季度就发布了更多。我想说我很幸运，我们培养的团队很棒，无论是研究方面的利益相关者还是研究产品管理团队。我觉得处理这一切的一个神奇之处在于，这不是个人运动。有一种强烈的责任感和团队协作，有时候确实像高强度运动，因为你面临非常关键的决策。有关于用户和训练的新信息，你必须迅速给出建议、判断和决定，没人能靠自己长期做到这一点。所以我认为真正的帮助是拥有一个了不起的团队，互相照顾，在发布前一晚，即使不是核心负责人，也会熬夜帮忙，审查博客文章，编辑，想出更好的演示，作为彼此的额外帮手。如果你独自承担所有这些变化，很容易……
你独自扛着一切，感觉自己孤立无援，好像所有事都得自己来。但我觉得Anthropic最神奇的一点，就是我们能发现那些互相帮助的机会，
然后真的更进一步，达到那种“心领神会”的境界。我们管这叫“进入蜂巢思维”。有篇文章专门讲过这个。我觉得这其中的一部分，就是让团队能够不断充电。不是说
我六月份刚休完假。不是说你可以休假，回来后事情就少了三倍。而是说，你可以放心休假，因为你知道团队能搞定该做的事，我们每个人
都能互相照应。所以我觉得这很重要。我个人也很幸运，我的伴侣非常支持我。这已经是我在AI领域工作的第六年了，从亚马逊到Anthropic，他看着我有多热爱
这项技术，以及它能带来什么，这真的很有帮助。从个人角度来说，也是如此。
——我很喜欢这些回答之间的关联。我听到的是，有其他人陪伴，与他人合作，依赖他人，在事情变得疯狂时互相帮助。这和你之前说的
如何在工作中找到快乐和乐趣的答案很相似。就是通过他人的启发，看看他们在做什么，
——一起合作。
——是的。有趣的是，最近Fiona来播客做客时，我问她软件工程界有什么变化，她指出现在更孤独了，因为我们在和智能体合作，
而不是和其他人。团队更小了，人们整天和一堆智能体对话。所以这提醒了我们，身边真实的其他人有多重要。
——我们被要求处理大事并做出决策，因为技术带来了更大的规模，对吧？我认为，如果有其他人能在某种程度上与你工作方式、你处理问题的方式产生共鸣——
也许不是每个细节都一致，但基本原则是什么？你做的假设是什么？这样他们就能为你提供支持，或者推动你的决策，让你的思维更敏锐。所以我觉得，
我们真的努力——我在组建团队、壮大团队、招聘时，会特别关注这一点：这个人是在乎自己的面子和构建庞大组织，还是他们在乎为Anthropic做贡献，
为团队的影响力做贡献，倾向于那些低调、以团队为导向的人。我觉得，这确实是可持续性的重要部分。
——是的，很多问题最终都归结到文化和招聘上。我听说了很多关于Anthropic为什么能如此快速前进的原因。我记得那个月每天都有新东西发布，
就像有一个发布日历，人们都在讨论这怎么可能。我听到很多是因为大家都对使命和价值观高度一致，这让大家能迅速做出决策。在我们进入
激动人心的快问快答环节之前，Dan，你还有什么想分享的吗？还有什么想补充的吗？或者想再强调一下我们聊过的内容吗？
——这其实很有趣，因为我觉得你的问题让我对自己这些思考的连接方式更加清晰了。我是你的真人版Claude。我真的很想传达的
一件事，或者说希望大家带走的，是工作方式上的一个要点，还有就是要认识到，这其中有大量的成长和变化，以及使用这项技术的乐趣。如果你此刻觉得
没有那么多最初的快乐了，那就想办法找到那些仍然充满热情的人，如果这是你感兴趣的领域，并且你想投入其中。我认为发展技能，以各种方式更新技能，比如
从第一性原理的角度思考你要解决什么问题。我想，虽然你没问我这个，但社区里确实有个疑问：当模型如此强大，工程师们积极参与时，我们还需要产品经理吗？
我认为，那些以用户为中心，深入理解用户想要达成什么目标，并将其以可操作的方式提炼出来，然后坚持不懈地做下去的人——
在我看来，这就是产品人员的核心。我实际上认为我们需要更多这样的人。我们变得非常技术驱动，但要让它产生影响力，你必须深入钻研，充满好奇心，而且要非常
亲力亲为。这些都是我认为帮助Anthropic在产品开发和模型开发方面取得成功的特质，也是文化的一部分。希望这对其他人也有价值。
——太棒了。真是个鼓舞人心的结尾。我的天。是的。这也是我长期以来一直在说的，现在构建东西很容易，难的是，正如你所说，我们该构建什么，以及我们构建的东西是不是
已经构建了正确、优秀、值得投入的东西，在我看来，这正是产品经理所做的，也是他们擅长的。
是的，是的，是的。而且这涉及到用户的细节。
是的。同理心。好的。太棒了。产品经理会成功的。好的。PRD没有死。[笑声]这里有各种各种重要的教训。嗯，Dan，我们到了非常激动人心的快速问答环节。我有五个问题要问你。准备好了吗？
准备好了。
第一个问题。你发现自己最常推荐给别人两三本书是什么？
一本是个人方面的，我非常喜欢《如何养育成年人》。我是一位母亲。我经常思考我想给孩子们灌输什么。那本书在描述我们不是在养育孩子，而是在养育成年人方面非常有帮助。
所以，这个框架是什么意思？我们想培养、磨练和培养孩子的哪些特质？呃，最近我在Audible上听的另一本书是
Eric Reese的《不可腐蚀》。
不可腐蚀，不可腐蚀，是的，是的。
是的。他最近是播客嘉宾。
嗯，是的。我觉得如何建立伟大公司的问题很重要。我个人对如何让优秀团队和伟大公司走得更远非常着迷。看到他对这个问题的框架和重新框架非常有趣。
我喜欢一些关于围绕文化设定指标的的例子。如果你不能，如果你只衡量收入，那就是你的前进方式，但如果你有
其他更好的指标，那实际上是维持你所关心价值观的方式。我一直在尝试思考如何将其落实到团队层面，比如我们如何更好地表达我们的规范，很多我们在团队里讨论的事情。
所以我觉得[哼]那也是一本很好的读物。
这就对了。呃，那将是你们大家的下一本必读书，当你们听这个的时候，Eric Greece那一集。
真是好一集。是的。
他的书也刚出版。《不可腐蚀》。
是的。
我觉得它好像是《纽约时报》畅销书。实际上它卖得非常好，我很高兴看到这一点。
是的，没错。
下一个问题。你最近喜欢看的电影或电视节目是什么？大多数Anthropic的人都没时间看东西，但我很好奇你有没有什么答案。我会说，上个月休假的时候，我确实去
狂刷了亚马逊Prime上的《辐射》。那其实我挺喜欢的，嗯，有点像，你听说过吗？
是的，是的，它是基于电子游戏的。
是的，它是基于电子游戏的。我认为它真的很有趣，很机智，很幽默，又超级注重动作。所以强烈推荐。
好的，下一个问题。你最近有没有发现特别喜欢的产品？
我确实觉得Claw Tag在产品体验上非常有趣。实际上，在Anthropic内部，我们有这个功能的不同版本，我认为它真的是一款非常非常强大的工具。
是的，感觉有些人可能会想，这有什么大不了的？但Anthropic所有人都在热烈讨论它，这告诉我这里正在发生重要的事情。我也在尝试把它接入
我的付费订阅者社区，我用的是Slack，那得多酷啊？
是的。
是的，我在尝试弄明白当它不是公司环境，而是一群互不认识的人时，它会如何运作。但我们在尝试。好的，还有两个问题。你最喜欢的人生格言是什么？你在工作或生活中经常想起的。
其实我生命头十年是祖父母带大的，我父母是美国的移民学生，他们攻读本科和硕士学位。
哇。我的祖父总是说：“无论你走多远，总还有更高的层次。”【笑声】我想，这确实是一种很好的方式，虽然他对人生哲学的描述相当激烈。但每当我们遇到新奇或前所未有的事情时，我都会想起这句话。我觉得今年上半年绝对有好多这样的时刻，我们学到了很多新东西。我就在学习，所以
总觉得还有另一座山，另一个机会
去达到更高的层次。
不够好，丹，我们要做得更好
我们要做得更大。这让我想到Ben Man在播客里说的另一句话：这是最正常的时候了，只会变得更奇怪、更疯狂。
是的，没错。好的，最后一个问题。我看了你的LinkedIn，你职业生涯早期在JP Morgan Chase做高收益债券交易员，你管理着一个价值上亿的匿名交易组合。你从那段经历中学到了什么，至今仍然铭记？或者那段时期有没有什么疯狂的故事？那是你生命中的四年。
我觉得我确实学到了很多，我在这里，在Anthropic以及之后的工作中都应用到了。在JP Morgan时，交易大厅你可以想象成“华夫饼华尔街”，那非常不同。大多数交易员
都面对终端，更多是在电脑上做分析。但那里仍然是男性主导的。所以，我是唯一的女性，也是唯一有我当时背景的人，在交易台。
我学到了两件事：第一，那是一个非常好的环境来建立真实的自我；第二，即使我是最资浅的人，即使我可能看起来不同，最好的想法和对最佳想法的坚定信念
是超越所有其他因素的，这才是最重要的。所以，我把这种理念带到了工作中。我和我的团队非常坦诚和真实。我努力确保
无论他们的级别或任期如何，如果他们有好的想法，我帮助他们去追求，同时我也这样做。把想法提出来，真正坚定信念，坚持到底，去做那些琐碎的工作来实现它。这些都是我从交易中学到的，而且我认为它们在许多方面适用于任何工作。
说得真好。人们如果关注你，在网上哪里可以找到你？听众怎么才能帮到你？
我在社交媒体上不太活跃。我觉得了解我和团队工作最好的方式是Anthropic博客，我们发布新模型、新产品体验的时候。至于说对我有用的，第一是你们的反馈。实际上，如果你在我们的任何产品界面上点赞或点踩，或者通过销售代表反馈对模型的意见，这些都会传到我们这里。
实际上，对于每个研究模型，我都会很深入地了解用户的喜好和反馈。所以，给我们反馈，推动Claude，告诉我们它哪里不足，这些都能帮助我们改进Claude。另外，如果你的网络里有符合我刚才描述的那种人才，我正在招人，团队在壮大。我们真的很喜欢热爱这项技术的人，有强烈好奇心、独立思考、敢于质疑假设的人，以及有那种动手折腾、黑客精神的人。
哇，梦寐以求的工作。基本上就是开放式的产品经理岗位，在Anthropic的研究团队里。
是的。
我觉得他们应该是在官网的职业页面申请吧。
对。
天哪，太好了。好了，我们开始吧。准备好迎接你们将要收到的大量简历洪流吧。
谢谢。[笑声]
丹，非常感谢你来到这里。
非常感谢你邀请我。谢谢你那些非常有帮助、引发思考的问题，甚至帮我理清了我们如何工作、整个技术如何融合以及作为产品人员在其中如何定位的思路。
我真的很感激。但说真的，丹，谢谢你。好了，大家再见。非常感谢你们的收听。如果你觉得这期有价值，可以在Apple Podcast、Spotify或你最喜欢的播客应用上订阅我们的节目。另外，
请考虑给我们一个评分或留下评论，这真的能帮助其他听众发现这个播客。你可以在lennispodcast.com找到所有过往的节目或了解更多信息。我们下期见。